hé il y avait dans les coulisses du
nouveau clip de Deadpool au clip mettant en vedette l'
hologramme de Céline Dion Je ne sais pas pourquoi
ils n'ont pas simplement envoyé la vraie Céline
eh bien je ne sais pas restreindre ce qui
restreint de toute façon je suis un peu nerveux
aussi ils ont '  Je n'ai pas fait de danse depuis que
j'ai quitté le Canada en 98 et
c'était entre deux poubelles entre les
adieux, donc j'ai besoin d'aider vraiment mon jeu
ici les os de mon corps ont été retirés,
y compris mes clavicules de sept pouces de
colonne vertébrale, c'est juste un peu plus
fluide est-ce qu'il y a des vrais seins ouais -
Coupe mais les miens - elle pense que je lui ai parlé
de toute façon
[Musique]